[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone hope you're all well
for those who don't know me i'm alex jen
i run this channel it consists mainly of
aikido content but also other martial
arts flow arts and some travel related
videos
i've put together a short three-part
series that documents my road trip from
the uk to russia back in 2018
my first video covers my journey there
taking ferries traveling through
scandinavia and visiting some national
parks
my second video contains highlights from
a week of aikido training i did in st
petersburg
and finally my third video shows my
journey back through eastern europe
and a little bit more aikido training
thrown in if you're looking forward to
the series make sure you hit the
notification button and remember to like
share and subscribe if you haven't done
so already
anyway until then take care and i'll
speak to you soon
you